هذا ونقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن مسؤولين
اسرائيليين ان اسرائيل تريد هدم العديد من
المداني في غزه القريبه من الحدود من اجل
انشاء منطقه امنيه وقال المسؤولون
الاسرائيليون ان اسرائيل تسعى لانشاء
منطقه عزله تصل الى نحو كيلومتر واحد على
طول حدود اسرائيل مع غزه واشار المسؤولون
الاسرائيليون الى ان الهدف من المنطقه
الزله هو ان تصعب على المسل حين
الفلسطينيين تكرار هجوم مشابه لهجمات
السابع من اكتوبر واضاف هؤلاء المسؤولون
انهم يسعون الى خلق الظروف الملائمه التي
من شانها اقناع الاسرائيليين الذين تم
اجلاؤهم بالعوده الى ديارهم وكان مقرر
الامم المتحده المعني بالاسكان الاكرا
شنان راجا جوبل قد قال ان التدمير
المنهجيه للمنازل الفلسطينيه على حدود غزه
يمكن ان يشكل جريمه حرب واضاف المقرر
الاممي المعني بالاسكان انه لا يوجد اي
بند في اتفاقيات جنف يبيح ما تفعله
اسرائيل على طول الحدود في قطاع غزه
ووصفها باعمال تطهير
لاملاك